do you think we would detect the the
technology the objects created by aliens
before we detect the aliens
possibly so when you're talking about
measuring assembly index
um don't you think we would detect the
garbage first
like at the outskirts of alien
civilizations this is gonna be trash
[Music]
i think i would come back to arecibo the
aracebo message sent from the aracebo
telescope built by
drake i think and and sagan how's our
sibo spelled
a-r-e-c-i-b-o yes thank you
and there we go they got out there that
that's the telescope that sent the
message that you're trying yeah so that
message was sent where it was beamed it
beamed at a star a specific star um and
it was sent out
many years ago um
and what they did so this is why i was
pushing on binary is a binary message
i think it's a semi-prime length number
of characters so i think 20 73 by 23 i
think and it basically represents human
bit proton
um binary human beings dna male and
female
and it's it's really cool
but i'm just wondering if um it could be
done
not making any because it's made
assumptions that aliens speak binary
make that assumption why not just assume
that if the difference between physics
chemistry and biology is the amount of
memory that's instead that's recordable
by the substrates
then surely the universal thing my i'm
going to make some sacrilegious
statement which i think is pretty
awesome
for people to argue with so this is uh
we're looking at an image
where it's the
the entirety of the message encoded in
binary
and then there's a probably
interpretation of different parts of
that image does it there's a person um
there's green parts it looks like uh for
people just listening like a tetra game
of tetris so it's encoding in minimal
ways a bunch of cool information
probably representing all of us so at
the top it's kind of teaching us how to
count and then all goes all the way down
teaching you chemistry and then just
says
but it makes so many assumptions and i
think if we can actually still
i think i mean sarah's much more
eloquent expressing this but i'll have a
go and you can correct me if you want
which is like um we one of the things
that sarah has had a profound effect on
the way i
look at the origin of life and this is
one of the reasons why we're working
together because
we don't really care about the origin of
life we want to make life make aliens
and find aliens make aliens find aliens
i think we might have to make aliens in
the lab before we find aliens in the
universe right i think that would be a
cool way to do it
so what is it about the universe that
creates alien aliens well it's selection
through assembly theory creating
memories because when you create
memories you can then command
your domain you can basically do stuff
you can command matter
so we need to find a way by
understanding what life is of how the
minimal way to command matter how that
would emerge in the universe
and be if we want to communicate i mean
maybe we don't want to necessarily
uniformly communicate
um what i would do perhaps if i had is i
would send out lots of probes
away from earth that have this magic way
of communicating with aliens get them
quite far away from earth
plausibly deniable and then send out the
message that would then attract all the
aliens and then basically work out if
they're a friend or foe and how they
want to hang out the messages being
something has to do with the memory yes
like the the assembly version of arecibo
so that everyone in the universe that
has been understands what life is
so aliens need to work out what they are
once they've worked out what they are
they then can work out how to encode
what they are and then they can go out
and send messages it's like the
universal um the rosetta stone
for life in the universe
is working out how the memories are
built i don't know if sarah you have any
well
um
whether that you would agree with that
no i i wanted to raise a different point
which is about the fact that we can't
see the aliens yet because we haven't
gotten the technology
and presumably we think assembly theory
is the right way of doing it but i don't
think that we know how to go from the
kind of data you're describing lex like
you know visual data or smell to
construct the assembly spaces yet and in
some ways i think that the problem of
life detection really is the same
problem at the foundations of ai
that we don't understand how to get
machines to
see causal graphs to see reality in
terms of causation
and so i i think assembly and ai are
going to intersect in interesting ways
hopefully
you